okay so if I had called and said hi I
really want to do this what would you
have said I don't know and I may have
been like my usual personality because I
don't really care about stuff like that
was to be like oh my god do it take the
money and run but because it was my
wedding it really wasn't business for me
it was such a special day I feel like it
takes away from the specialness it feels
awful that my sister used my wedding as
a business opportunity she chose
the money over me that's why she never
truly asked me it's not that she forgot
to ask me or thought that I wouldn't
care I think that she wouldn't have
known what to do if my answer was no